this chart shows the yield on the German
government's 30-year bonds over the past
few months you'll notice something
unusual happened in early August the
yield dropped below zero a yield is the
return investors receive on a bond a
negative yield is the opposite meaning
investors are receiving less money than
they originally paid negative yields are
a relatively new feature in the world's
bond markets but they're appearing with
increasing frequency globally around 16
trillion dollars worth of bonds
currently carry a negative yield bonds
are one of the safest investments on the
market they're staples of many
investment portfolios from pension funds
to retirement accounts investors like
them because of their reliable returns
so how did some bond yields go negative
and why would investors keep putting
their money in assets with negative
returns to understand negative yields
you need to understand how bonds work
bonds are a form of debt the
government's and companies issue for
various lengths of time a bonds lifespan
can range from a few weeks to a few
decades bond issuers make regular
interest payments to bondholders over
the assets lifespan this is known as the
coupon rate but bonds are often bought
and sold on the secondary market their
prices fluctuate which affects what an
investor can expect to earn the yield is
a calculation of how much an investor
can expect to make from holding onto a
bond bought at a particular price for a
particular length of time the yield of a
bond is inversely related to its price
high demand in the bond market drives up
prices and drives down yields this is
largely why yields are negative right
now the bond market is experiencing
unusually high demand there are a few
reasons for this
the first is that investors have grown
increasingly concerned about the lack of
growth in the global economy amid low
inflation political uncertainty and
trade disputes investors are putting
more money into safer assets like bonds
the second is that several central banks
around the world have set their interest
rates below zero central banks are banks
for commercial banks so when they set
negative interest rates commercial banks
must pay them for the privilege of
holding their money this incentivizes
commercial banks to lower the interest
rates they charge - so far commercial
banks have been reluctant to pass that
negative rate to average consumers but
some have passed on the cost to
companies and large institutional
investors negative rates give investors
an incentive to buy bonds rather than
park their money at a bank this drives
up demand these factors have pushed bond
prices higher and driven down yields so
much so that they are now in negative
territory and in some cases even below
the negative rates set by central banks
so why would investors continue to buy
bonds with negative yields well if
demand continues to rise buying now
means potentially selling bonds later at
a higher price this can help offset
losses in the short term but the
long-term implications of negative
yields could mean lower returns on
pensions and retirement accounts meaning
workers might have to save more and work
longer negative bond yields and negative
interest rates in general are viewed as
a short-term remedy to get economies
moving but with the footprint of
negative rates getting deeper and wider
investors worry that they may be less of
a temporary fix and more of a permanent
fixture in the market